Rose Tico fans can claim a victory, well,
sort of.
An alleged summary of the Star Wars: The Rise
of Skywalker script has emerged on YouTube
from a former professional screenplay reader
named Robert Burnett.
This supposed version of the script is said
to have been written during Colin Trevorrow's
time in the director's chair, before he lost
his job in 2017 and the entire project started
over with The Force Awakens director J.J.
Abrams back at the helm.
This script, with the working title The Duel
of the Fates, appears to be a profoundly different
movie from the one we received in December
2019, though several of the individual concepts
are similar enough that they might have been
repurposed for The Rise of Skywalker.
The story itself, however, is entirely different,
and Kelly Marie Tran's Rose Tico is at its
core.
"I work behind pipes all day.
Doing talking with resistance heroes is not
my forte.
I'm Rose."
Fans of Rose, who was introduced in The Last
Jedi, have been upset by how The Rise of Skywalker
minimized her presence and insulted the character,
on top of the real-life harassment Tran experienced
on social media because of her role.
They can perhaps find some bittersweet comfort
in the possibility that, somewhere along the
line, someone might have cared about Rose.
However, we can't 100% guarantee that the
alleged script described in the video is genuine.
Burnett explains straight away that he won't
provide proof of the script beyond cropped
images of the title page and the original
narration crawl, or any detail as to how he
got a hold of it, but if you want to imagine
this is legit, hey, go for it.
Let's take a look at the version of Rose Tico
in The Rise of Skywalker that might have been.
This alleged original Rise of Skywalker script
actually opens on Rose Tico and BB-8.
A good chunk of the first act has her attempting,
along with Finn, Poe, and eventually Rey,
to sabotage the transportation of ore used
for building Star Destroyers at the Kuat Shipyards.
Long story short, the sabotage goes very poorly
for our heroes, but with luck, they escape
(are you ready for this?) by jacking an entire
freaking Star Destroyer off the lot and peeling
out of the shipyards at lightspeed.
All the while, Rose is described as being
front and center, doing her best to reorganize
when plans A, B, and Z all fail.
There are two major teams performing missions
in this alleged script: Rey, Poe, and Chewbacca
take off on their own to do their half, while
Rose, Finn, C3PO, and R2-D2 depart for Coruscant
to try a desperate gamble.
In trying to snuff out the Resistance for
good, the First Order has choked off all intersystem
communication at its source.
Rey learns from the texts she picked up in
The Last Jedi, however, that the Jedi Temple
houses a giant kyber crystal that the Old
Republic used thousands of years ago as a
communication system the First Order doesn't
have the means to control.
Lighting this ancient beacon is the last hope
of the Resistance to gather allies, and Rose
takes point on this do-or-die mission.
Once the beacon subplot is completed on Coruscant,
the alleged Rise of Skywalker script continues
on into the city itself.
Since the fall of the Republic as we knew
it in the Star Wars prequel trilogy, the city-planet
has taken a major hit, with most citizens
falling into scavenging and homelessness.
Rose and Finn navigate this underclass and
eventually help incite a revolt.
You heard that right: the woman who lost the
only family she had left in a civil war gets
to assist inciting the biggest on-screen popular
revolt against fascism in Star Wars, in Coruscant.
Quite a climax.
This all takes place while a massive battle
occurs in orbit over Coruscant, with General
Leia's forces united by Lando Calrissian.
The cherry on top is mentioned in passing
by Burnett as he wraps up the video: Once
the First Order is defeated, the remaining
leadership attempt to flee from Coruscant
in a giant mobile headquarters.
At some point in the story that Burnett doesn't
describe, Rose messes with the compound's
navigation computers and when the complex
goes to lightspeed, the travel vectors are
incorrect and it crashes into a planet, destroying
the Order for good.
It's not as elegant as a one-in-a-million
shot into an exhaust port, but that is wicked
cool.
Sadly, since there's no proof that any of
that is actually true, you're gonna have to
take it with a grain of salt.
In fact, though it might have existed at one
point, fans of Rose might rather pretend the
screenplay draft didn't.
After all, all it would be is a reminder of
something they got cheated out of.
The past three years have been tumultuous
for the Star Wars franchise between the backlash
over The Last Jedi and failure of Solo, and
Trevorrow's professional merit seemed to have
dropped after his film Book of Henry utterly
bombed at the box office.
Being the poster boy for the biggest franchise
on Earth must have been a lot of pressure
at the time, and it appears that maybe in
the end, a bunch of fallible humans cracked
underneath it.
Despite the mixed overall response to The
Rise of Skywalker, many people did in fact
enjoy it, and that's the legacy of Star Wars
as a whole: it's too many things to too many
people, and there's no way in hell it could
ever please everybody.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.